MEMBERS
THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN
SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER REAVIS
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND
BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW LOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES
CHAU GEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER
KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY
LEAD LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN MURATSUCHI THIS AREA
IN WHEN O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE TEEN BELLA THERE IS V.
APPROVED BY VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YES YOUR CON YOU MONEY IS HERE
IN THE NAME OF GOD THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL
MAY GOD BLESS OUR NATION AND
THOSE WHO SERVE IT WITH THE
COURAGE TO APPRECIATE THE
DIFFERENCES AMONGST US THAT
MAKES THAT MAKE OUR COUNTRY
GREAT AND MAYBE WORK TO
PRESERVE A NATION THAT IS BOUND
TOGETHER BY LIBERTY JUSTICE
AND TOLERANCE MAY GOD BLESS
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS WHO ARE
OUR HEROES FIGHTING ON THE
FRONTLINES TIRELESSLY RISKING
THEIR LIVES OUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS ARE WITH THOSE THAT
LOST THEIR LOVED ONES AMONG
THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PLUS AMERICANS DO TO COVER
NINETEEN AND WHAT THE MILLIONS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD I MEAN
THANK YOUR MOM IS THERE WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG STATE
SEN
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED
MOVING TO THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
FRIDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH MOVES
AND MISTER FLORES SECONDS THAT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED
WITH PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ARE ABSENCES
FOR TODAY FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TOM LONGER AND FOR MEDICAL
LEAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
FRAZIER AND QUIRK
MISTRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
GONZALEZ MATHIS AG WE ARE CURRY
HOLDEN AND RODRIGUEZ TO SPEAK
ON AN INTERN ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER
MEMBERS
THERE ARE ITEMS ON YOUR DESK
TODAY THE BOOKS ARE COURTESY
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IN HONOR OF
BLACK HISTORY MONTH AND THE
COOKIES ARE COURTESY OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN CELEBRATION OF
QUORUM PLEASE DO NOT OPEN OR
CONSUME THE COOKIES UNTIL YOU
LEAVE THE CHAMBER THANK YOU
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE FILE ITEM ONE HR
FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
HOUSE RESOLUTION FOURTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA GIRLS
AND WOMEN IN SPORTS WEEK
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO MR
WHEN MR WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT HOUSE
RESOLUTION FOURTEEN WHICH
COMMEMORATES THE FIRST WEEK
OF FEBRUARY AS CALIFORNIA
GIRLS AND WOMEN IN SPORTS
WEEK CALIFORNIA WOMEN HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED INCREDIBLE FEATS
IN SPORTS HAVING COMPETED
ADMIRABLY AT THE NATIONAL
AND INTERNATIONAL STAGE
YEAR AFTER YEAR BUT BEYOND
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE
COMPETITION SPORTS ARE A
POSITIVE FORCE FOR PHYSICAL
MENTAL AND OVERALL WELL BEING
SPEAKING FROM EXPERIENCE I
COMPUTED ATHLETICS THROUGHOUT
COLLEGE AT UCSD AS AN ACADEMIC
ALL AMERICAN SWIMMER A
COLLEGIATE ROWER AND A WATER
POLO PLAYER FOR TWO YEARS AND
MY DAUGHTER WAS -- COLLEGIATE
GROWER AS WELL AS AN ATHLETE
I HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE
IMPACT THAT SPORTS HAVE ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF GIRLS AND WOMEN
AS THEY PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
TO CULTIVATE LEADERSHIP AND
GROW SELF ESTEEM I MYSELF LEARN
THE SKILLS OF DISCIPLINE AND
PERSEVERANCE WHICH SERVED ME
WELL IN THIS BODY PARTICIPATING
IN ATHLETICS HAS LASTING
IMPACTS FOR EXAMPLE EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THE FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED FEMALE EXECUTIVES GREW
UP PLAYING SPORTS RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN THAT THAT GIRLS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN SPORTS ARE LESS
LIKELY TO SMOKE EXPERIENCE
TEENAGE PREGNANCY AND HAVE
LOWER RATES OF DEPRESSION THAT
SAID NOT ALL GIRLS AND WOMEN
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO SPORTS
OR TRAIN ARE TREATED WITH
THE SAME LEVEL OF RESPECT BY
THEIR PEERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
THE WOMEN'S SPORTS FOUNDATION
COLLECTS AND PUBLISHES DATA
ON GENDER DISPARITY AND WITHIN
ATHLETICS ANNUALLY BOYS GET ONE
POINT ONE MILLION MORE SPORTS
OPPORTUNITY THAN GIRLS I MYSELF
HAD TO SWIM ON THE BOYS SWIM
TEAM SINCE IT WAS NO GIRLS
SWIM TEAM AT MY HIGH SCHOOL
WOMEN ATHLETES AND COACHES
FACE EXPLICIT AND IMPLICIT
BIASES THAT LIMIT THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES AND DEPRIVE THEM
OF SELF IMPROVEMENT AND HINDERS
THEIR QUALITY OF PLAY THIS
RESOLUTION BRINGS AWARENESS TO
THE DISPARITY THAT REMAINS AND
HOPEFULLY INSPIRES GIRLS AND
YOUNG WOMEN TO REMAIN ENGAGED
IN ATHLETICS AND SEEK TO
COMPETE AT THE COLLEGIATE AND
PROFESSIONAL LEVELS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN CELEBRATING ALL GIRLS AND
WOMEN WHO PARTICIPATE IN SPORTS
MEMBERS
I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE CONTINUE
TO RESPECT THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SAYING THAT WE ARE
HEARING TO ON THIS FLOOR
AND KEEP YOUR VOICES TO A
MINIMUM SO WE CAN HEAR THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE SPEAKING YES
WORKS OVER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE TO IN
SUPPORT OF HR FOR TEAM TITLE
NINE WHICH PROHIBITS SEX
DISCRIMINATION IN ANY EDUCATION
PROGRAM OR ACTIVITY RECEIVING
FRED FEDERAL ASSISTANCE HAS
MADE MUCH MORE OF AN IMPACT
THAT MANY OF US ARE AWARE
I WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHEN
I WAS A YOUNG GIRL GOING
TO JUNIOR HIGH AND WE JUST
OPENED UP OUR INDEPENDENCE
PARK SWIMMING PROGRAM I MYSELF
COMING FROM A FAMILY OF TEN
A LATINO FAMILY NONE OF US
KNEW HOW TO SWIM AND BECAUSE
MY MOTHER DID NOT KNOW HOW TO
SWIM SHE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WOULD LEARN TO SWIM
SO WE WALKED OVER TO THIS PARK
AND I LEARNED TO SWIM THAT WAS
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX IN JUNIOR
HIGH WHEN I ENTERED HIGH SCHOOL
KNOWING ALREADY HOW TO SWIM I
WAS VERY EXCITED TO HEAR THAT
THERE WAS A WATER POLO TEAM
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ENCOURAGES SAID THERE WAS A
WATER POLO TEAM BUT THERE WAS
NOT A WOMEN'S WATER POLO TEAM
SO I WENT UP TO THE COACH AND
TOLD HIM I WANTED TO SOME SWIM
ON THE WATER POLO TEAM D.
MUCH LAUGHED IN MY FACE AND
SAID GO AHEAD AND SHOW ME
IF YOU CAN SWIM AND ESSENCE
TRY OUT WITH MANY YOUNG MEN
WATCHING I SWIM ACROSS THE
POOL AND HE SAID YOU CAN BE
ON THE TEAM BUT THAT'S WHAT
IT WAS LIKE FORTY FIVE YEARS
AGO FOR SOMEBODY LIKE ME
YOU ARE OUT OF ORDER
MAN YOU'RE BEING DESTRUCTIVE
WE WILL MOVE ON
MA'AM
YOU ARE OUT OF ORDER
MA'AM YOU'RE BEING DISRUPTIVE
THANK YOU
MS CLARK SILVA YOU MAY CONTINUE
IN ADDITION AS I WAS EVEN
YOUNGER THAN JUNIOR HIGH AND
A SWIMMER I PLAYED ON WHAT WE
CALLED BASEBALL BUT WE CALLED
IT BOBBY SOCKS SO WE HAVE MADE
A HUGE GROWTH IN WOMEN'S IN
SPORTS AND HOW MANY OF US CAN
BELIEVE THAT JUST THIS YEAR
JUST THIS YEAR WE NOW
HAVE A WOMEN REFEREE
WE ALSO HAVE WOMEN WHO ARE
COACHES IN PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
MEN'S SPORTS BUT I WANT TO
AND WITH AS I GREW OLDER AND
SWAM FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND TRANSFERRED TO UCLA I
ACTUALLY WORKED AT THE JOHN
WOODEN CENTER AND FOR MANY OF
YOU WHO KNOW AND FOLLOW JOHN
WOODEN YOU DON'T KNOW THAT IS
PYRAMID OF SUCCESS IS BASED
OFF PILLARS OF CHARACTER STREAM
HONESTY INTEGRITY FRIENDSHIP
DISCIPLINE PERSEVERANCE IN
SPORTS IN FACT IN STEALS
ALL OF THOSE AND THAT'S WHY
IT IS VITAL THAT WOMEN HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PLAY SPORT
TO EXCEL IN SPORTS AND AS
WAS MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE
MANY MANY OF US ON THIS FLOOR
WERE ATHLETES AND IT'S BECAUSE
THAT DRIVE FROM BEING AN
ATHLETE WHO'S FORWARDED TO
YOUR PROFESSIONAL CAREERS I
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT HR FOURTEEN
THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA
YEAH MISS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER YOUNG WASN'T GOING TO
SPEAK TODAY BUT IT REMINDED
ME OF -- IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES I KNOW IT'S A LONG
TIME WHEN YOU WERE BORN BUT I
PLAYED BASKETBALL FOR WINTERS
HIGH SCHOOL AT THE TIME WE
ONLY GOT TO PLAY HALF COURT
AND THE REASON WE ONLY GOT TO
PLAY HALF COURT IS BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT THE WOMEN B.
B. TWO WINDED I WOULDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH ENERGY FOR AN
ENTIRE GAME SO TIMES HAVE
CHANGED AS TIMES CHANGED --
MY DAUGHTER INTO P.
BEING ONE OF THE TOP BASKETBALL
PLAYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I AM SO PROUD
TODAY THAT WE STAND IN SUPPORT
OF HR FOURTEEN IS THE TIMES OF
CHANGE THE IMPORTANCE OF SPORTS
THE PLAN PORTENTS OF HAVING OUR
WOMEN OUT THERE AND -- WORKING
TOGETHER IN A TEAM ENVIRONMENT
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT'S SO IMPORTANT
WE'VE SEEN OUR CHILDREN ARE
WOMEN BEING ABLE TO PLAY IN SO
MANY SPORTS TWO YEARS AGO WE
WERE UNABLE TO DO SO SO THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING US TODAY
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
MISTER BENNETT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'VE I RISE TO IN
SUPPORT OF -- H. R.
FOURTEEN AND APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM VENTURA --
BRINGING THAT UP TO ONE POINT
OUT JUST ONE STATISTIC THAT
WHILE I WAS A HIGH SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR -- STUDIES FOUND
THAT LATINO WOMEN WHO WERE
ENGAGED IN SPORTS IN HIGH
SCHOOL HAD VIRTUALLY AS ZERO
PREGNANCY RATE IN HIGH SCHOOL
-- AND IT WAS A DRAMATIC
STATISTICAL DIFFERENCE --
AND SO THERE IS TREMENDOUS
BENEFITS TO HAVING -- SPORTS
AVAILABLE FOR WOMEN AND WE'VE
REALLY SEEN THAT CHANGE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
WHEN YOU MAY CLOSE -- I ASKED
AT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS THANK YOU MR ONE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
NATURE FOURTEEN THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR FOURTEEN
ALL MEMBERS VOTE HE DESIRED
ABOUT THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
-- THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THAT THERE ARE
SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHOR SO NATURE
FOURTEEN WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE ALL OPPOSED SAY NO THE
AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED LIVING OUT OF
VIOLATE INTO A C.
R. SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BY
SIN REMEMBER THREE OF US
RELATIVE TO INTRODUCE A
GIRL TO ENGINEERING DAY
THIS RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MATT MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I AM EXCITED TO
PRESENT ACR SIXTEEN WHICH
RECOGNIZES TODAY AS INTRODUCE
A GIRL TO ENGINEERING DAY
DESPITE RECENT PROGRESS WOMEN
CONTINUE TO BE SEVERELY UNDER
REPRESENTED IN THE ENGINEERING
FIELDS AS A FEMALE ENGINEER I
KNOW THIS UNDER REPRESENTATION
TO WELL WHEN I WORKED AS AN
ELECTRICAL ENGINEER AFTER
GRADUATING FROM MIT I WAS OFTEN
THE ONLY WOMAN IN THE ROOM
AND ALWAYS THE ONLY WOMAN OF
COLOR ROUTE MY CAREER I HAVE
HEARD PEOPLE SAY THAT YOUNG
WOMEN DO NOT PURSUE ENGINEERING
CAREERS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN STEM BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT AS FOUNDER OF A
NONPROFIT WITH A MISSION TO
SPARK INTEREST IN TECHNOLOGY
AND ENGINEERING AMONG VERY
YOUNG GIRLS I CAN TELL YOU THAT
GIRLS ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
STEM WE SIMPLY NEED TO GIVE
YOUNG WOMEN CONTINUOUS EXPOSURE
ENCOURAGEMENT AT THE TOOLS
THAT THEY NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER WOULD YOU LIKE
A FIRST ROLE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS YES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
ACR SIXTEEN AND ASKED THAT
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN TO CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU THROUGH WITH
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR --
FOR ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON ACR SIXTEEN ON MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THOUGH THERE ARE SEVENTY
FOUR CO AUTHORS ON ACR SIXTEEN
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE OPPOSED
SAY NO THE AYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING
TO FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY
EIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND ACT RELATING TO THE
BUDGET ACT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MISTER KING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THINK ABOUT THE SPEAKER TODAY
WE ARE SWAPPING BUDGET BILL
VEHICLES WITH THE SENATE I'M
PRESENTING AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT
AND EIGHTY FIVE OTHER BILLS FOR
THIS PURPOSE SENDING THE BILL
TO THE SENATE WILL ALLOW US
TO EXPEDITE OUR BUDGET PROCESS
-- THIS COMING JUNE WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT AND THAT'S THE ROLE BE
SUBSTITUTED FOR THE REMAINING
EIGHTY FIVE BILLS AB ONE TWENTY
NINE TO AB TWO THIRTEEN THANK
YOU MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
M. SPEAKER -- MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IN OPPOSITION OF THESE
EIGHTY SIX EMPTY BUDGET BILLS
I REPEAT WE ARE VOTING ON IT
EIGHTY SIX EMPTY BILLS WITH
NO SUBSTANCE AND NO DETAILS
MEMBERS WE ARE SERVING IN A
TIME WHERE OUR STATE IS FACING
MULTIPLE CRISES AT ONE TIME
NEVER IN OUR HISTORY WILL BE
A WILL BE ABLE TO SAY THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH A PANDEMIC
WE'RE GETTING A RECESSION
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE NEED
THAT OUR SCHOOLS NEED TO BE RE
OPENED FOR OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
TEACHERS AND OUR PARENTS WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE FACT THAT
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE TRAPPED
IN A BROKEN EDT SYSTEM WE'RE
DEALING WITH AFTER THE FACT
THAT A NEW WILDFIRE SEASON
IS STARTING OR PROBABLY NEVER
ENDED WE'RE DEALING WITH THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE HOMELESSNESS
ON THE RISE WE NEED A BUDGET
PROCESS OF SUBSTANCE OF DETAIL
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE DEMANDING
THAT THEY'RE DEMANDING A PLAN
FORWARD TO DEAL WITH THESE
CRISES AND THESE CRITICAL
CHALLENGES IT IS GOING TO
BE SAID THAT THIS IS THE WAY
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN DONE BUT
WE HAS LEGISLATURE LITTLE AS
LEGISLATORS ARE CHALLENGED TO
CHANGE THAT DYNAMIC TO LOOK FOR
WAYS TO IMPROVE THE PROCESS WE
SHOULDN'T USE THE ARGUMENT OF
THE COMEDIAN SEE TO IGNORE THE
FACT THAT WE NEED MORE BUDGET
TRANSPARENCY AND SO THE WE NEED
A BUDGET PROCESS THAT ENSURES
THAT THERE IS MORE PUBLIC
INPUT TO ENSURE THE INTEGRITY
OF THIS OF THIS BODY INTO AND
MAXIMIZES TRANSPARENCY AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE IN THIS PROCESS
UNFORTUNATELY DOES NOT DO THAT
AND I URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU
MR FONG MR SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER KING WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
-- I ALWAYS PRIDE MYSELF EVERY
YEAR IN THE FACT THAT OUR
COMMITTEE THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
HAS THE MOST ROBUST OPEN PUBLIC
PROCESS OF ANY COMMITTEE HERE
IN THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY --
ANY GIVEN YOUR WE HAVE OVER
A HUNDRED HEARINGS WITH HOURS
AND HOURS OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY
IN FACT -- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO WHO CHAIRS SUB ONE WAS
HERE PAST MIDNIGHT ON MONDAY
NIGHT I BELIEVE -- HEARING
MANY MANY ITEMS AND -- STAYING
TILL I THINK ONE O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING TO HEAR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY SO I THINK THE ISSUES
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIGGEST
WOULD RAISE THESE ARE ABSOLUTE
WERE IN COMPLETE AGREEMENT
THESE ARE ACTUALLY ISSUES ARE
TOP OF MIND AND WE ARE DEALING
WITH THEM AS WE SPEAK IN OUR
COMMITTEE WHETHER IT'S IN
SOMEONE'S LOOKING AT SCHOOLS
WITH THE TO THE SUB FLOOR WE
JUST HAD A HEARING ON THE D. D.
THESE ARE HEARINGS THAT WE ARE
HAVING AS WE SPEAK THERE ARE
COMMITTEE PROCESS THESE BILLS
ARE JUST PART OF THE PROCESS
TO ENSURE THAT COME JUNE WE'RE
READY TO PASS A BUDGET AND
MAKE SURE IT'S BALANCED TO MAKE
SURE IT'S ON TIME THANK YOU
FOR WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU MISTER KING
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
LONG MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ON AVERAGE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FOR FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PER FILE ITEMS
FOUR THROUGH EIGHTY EIGHT AB
IS ONE TWENTY NINE THROUGH
TWO THIRTEEN INCLUSIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE TWENTY NINE HIGHS FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN SOME OF THE
ONE THIRTY FIVE FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN SUMMER ONE THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY SOME OF THE ONE THIRTY
TWO FOUR KNOW SEVENTY SOME
OF THE ONE THIRTY THREE FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME OF THE ONE
THIRTY FOUR FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
DECEMBER ONE THIRTY FIVE WARNER
SEVENTY SOME OF THE ONE THIRTY
SIX FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
SUMMER ONE THIRTY SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS ONE SEVEN SUMMER
ONE THIRTY EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS ONCE SOMEONE WANTS TO
MAKE SOME OF THE ONE THIRTY
NINE FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY ONE FORTY I SIXTY FOUR
NO SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY ONE FORTY
ONE FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY
TO FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY THREE
I FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY
FOUR FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY FIVE
FOURNIS SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FORTY SIX FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FORTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY ONE FORTY
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY NINE
FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN SIMPLY
ONE FIFTY FIVE FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN SOME OF THE ONE FIFTY
ONE CORNER SEVENTEEN SOME OF
THE ONE FIFTY TWO FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FIFTY THREE FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTY SOME OF THE ONE FIFTY
FOUR FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME
OF THE ONE FIFTY FIVE FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN SOME OF THE
ONE FIFTY SIX FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTY SOME OF THE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY
SOME OF A ONE FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FIFTY NINE FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN SOME OF THE ONE SIXTY
FIVE FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
SUMMER ONE SIXTY ONE FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTY SOME LEGAL ONE SIXTY
TWO FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
SUMMER ONE SIXTY THREE FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME OF THE
ONE SIXTY FOUR FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTY SUMMER ONE SIXTY FIVE
FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY SUMMER
ONE SIXTY SIX OR NO SEVENTEEN
SUMMER ONE SIXTY SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN SUMMER ONE
SIXTY EIGHT FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN SOME OF THE ONE SIXTY
NINE FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
SOME OF THE ONE SEVENTY FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN SOME OF THE
ONE SEVENTY ONE OR NO SEVENTY
ONE SEVENTY TWO FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTY SOME OF THE ONE
SEVENTY THREE FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN SUMMER ONE SEVENTY
FOUR FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME
OF THE ONE SEVENTY FIVE FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME OF THE
ONE SEVENTY SIX FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTY SOME OF THE ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN OR NO SEVENTEEN SUMMER
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTEEN SOME OF THE ONE
SEVENTY NINE SEVENTY SOME OF
THE ONE EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTY SYMBOL ONE EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME
EVERYONE EIGHTY TWO SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY THREE
FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME
OF THE ONE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN SOME OF THE
ONE EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTY SYMBOL ONE EIGHTY
SIX CORNERS SEVENTEEN SYMBOL
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTEEN SOME OF THE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT OR NO SEVENTEEN
SOME OF THE ONE EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN SUMMER
ONE NINETY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
SOMEBODY ONE ANYONE BORN IS
SEVENTY SOME OF THE ONE NINETY
TWO FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY
SUMMER ONE NINETY THREE FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTY ONE NINETY
FOUR FIFTY FOUR NO SEVEN SOME
OF THE ONE NINETY FIVE FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTY SUMMER ONE
NINETY SIX FIFTY FOUR NO SEVEN
DECEMBER ONE NINETY SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME OF THE
ONE NINETY EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTEEN SUMMER ONE NINETY
NINE FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY
SOME LEGAL TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME WIGGLE
TWO ONE FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY
SOME LEGAL TOOL TO I.
FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME
WIGGLE TWO OH THREE I FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTY SOME LEGAL
TOOL FOR FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY
SYMBOL TOOL FIVE FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTY SYMBOL TWO OH SIX
FIVE FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTY
CYNICAL TOOL SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
NO SEVENTEEN SOME PEOPLE TO
-- EIGHT ICE FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTY SOME PEOPLE TO NINE
FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN SOME
LEGAL TO TEN FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVEN SYMBOL TO ELEVEN FIFTY
FOUR NO SEVENTEEN SOME LEGAL TO
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
INNOCENT PEOPLE TO THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU TO THE READING CLERK
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL
IS NOW LIFTED AND WE WILL
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
MEMBERS OF THE QUORUM
CALL HAS BEEN LIFTED I
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
ARE GRANTED PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AN INTERMINABLY MR
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY
I THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
TODAY I'M HERE TO TALK
WITH A HEAVY HEART
BUT THE PASSING OF
CHARLES HOLLIS CLARK
SOME PEOPLE NEW MISS
CHARLES BUT TO HIS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS HE WAS KNOWN AS
CHARLIE CHUCK AND TO LIZA
WAS KNOWN AS CHARLES CHUCK
WAS KNOWN AS GRANDPA JAZZY
IT THEY OFTEN SAY THAT HE
JUDGE OF FRUIT AND A TREE
BY TASTE THE FRUIT IN THE
QUALITY OF FOOD IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE MORE TALK
ABOUT A FAMILY WHO'S GOT THE
PARTS AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
AND IT WAS RAISE THE FAMILY
INTERGENDER VERY MUCH
GOOD FOR THE COMMUNITIES
CHARLES REYES THAT HELPED RAISE
DOMINICA ELIJAH AND SAMANTHA
BUT ALSO HELPED RAISED
NICOLE A FRIEND OF OURS
A DEAR FAMILY FRIEND
CHARLES WAS SOMEBODY WHO
HAD A HUGE HEART WHO LOVED
EVERYTHING ABOUT LIFE AND
LOVE DAHLE PEOPLE AROUND HIM
AND WHEN HE MET NICOLE THE
TWELVE YEARS OF AGE HE COULDN'T
HELP BUT TO EMBRACE AND
TO BE THAT STEPFATHER THAT
HELPED HER HELPED HER GET
THROUGH LIFE AND THEN HELP
HER BE THE WOMAN SHE IS TODAY
SOME BEHALF OF ALISA
DOMINICA SAMANTHA NICOLE
HIS WIFE IS WHAT THE EXIT
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
MS GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MISTER JOHN SWEENEY
WHO MOST RECENTLY SERVED AS
THE PRESIDENT EMERITUS OF THE
AFL-CIO IT SWEENEY LIVED A
LIFE CENTERED ON THE STRUGGLES
PRIDE ASPIRATIONS OF WORKING
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY BORN IN
A WORKING CLASS NEIGHBORHOOD
IN THE BRONX HE WAS RAISED BY
HIS FATHER A UNION BUS DRIVER
AND MOTHER A DOMESTIC WORKER
PRESIDENTS WE LEARN THE POWER
OF COLLECTIVE WORKER VOICES
AFTER WITNESSING HIS FATHER'S
PASSION FOR HIS UNION IN SEEN
WHAT IT ACCOMPLISHED FOR HIS
FAMILY SOLID WAGES VACATION
DAYS AND A SENSE OF CIVIC DUTY
HE FIRST JOINED A UNION IN
COLLEGE WHEN HE HELD JOBS AS
A GRAVE DIGGER AND A BUILDING
PORTER AFTER COLLEGE PRESIDENT
SWEENEY WENT ON TO TAKE ON
VARIOUS ROLES IN OTHER UNIONS
INCLUDING THE INTERNATIONAL
LADIES GARMENT WORKERS UNION A
PREDECESSOR TO UNITE HERE AND
FINALLY A CHAU IT WAS THAT S.
C. ARE YOU THAT HE BEGIN TO
TRANSFORM WORKERS ORGANIZING
AND CHAMPIONED A MORE INCLUSIVE
LABOR MOVEMENT AFTER LEADING
US ARE YOU LOCAL THIRTY TWO
BJ NEW YORK FOR SEVERAL YEARS
PRESIDENT SWEENEY ASCENDED
TO THE PRESIDENCY OF SEIU
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY WHERE
HE FOCUSED ON CHAMPION THE
CAUSE OF LOW WAGE WORKERS
AND IMMIGRANT RIGHTS UNDER
PRESIDENTS WHEN HE'S LEADERSHIP
ESSAY YOU LAUNCH THE JUSTICE
FOR JANITORS CAMPAIGN AMASSED
CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE CAMPAIGN
CENTERED IN LOS ANGELES WHICH
SOUGHT TO GIVE JANITORS THE
WAGES BENEFITS AND DIGNITY THEY
DESERVE ON THE JOB THAT FIGHT
CONTINUES TODAY HE CARRIED
HIS VISION WORKER ORGANIZING
TO THE AFL CIO WHERE HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE PRESIDENCY IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THERE
PRESIDENT'S WHEN YOU CONTINUE
TO CHAMPION THE CAUSE OF AN
INCLUSIVE LABOR MOVEMENT BY
PUSHING FOR RECRUITING A MORE
DIVERSE LEADERSHIP EMBRACING
IMMIGRANT WORKERS INCLUDING
THOSE THAT ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND
RECRUITING YOUNG PEOPLE INTO
LABOR MOVEMENT THROUGH UNION
SUMMER PRESENCE MEANS LIFE
WAS DRIVEN BY HIS PASSION FOR
WORKING FAMILIES AND HE WAS
UNAPOLOGETIC ABOUT FIGHTING
FOR MOST VULNERABLE I OFTEN
THINK ABOUT MY OWN JOURNEY
INTO ORGANIZED LABOR AND WHEN
I STARTED AS THE HEAD OF THE
LOCAL AFL-CIO IT WAS PRESIDENT
SWEENEY WHO LED THE NATIONAL
AFL-CIO IN ON MY FIRST MEETING
WITH HIM HE PULLED ME ASIDE
EIGHT ABA PRESIDENT OF THE
HOTEL CHAIN HAD CALLED HIM
ABOUT SOMETHING WE ARE DOING
IN SAN DIEGO THEY CALLED HIM TO
COMPLAIN BECAUSE WE ARE HOLDING
UP A PROJECT AND SO HE WAS JUST
GOING TO ASK ME EXACTLY WHAT
WE WERE DOING AND WHY I WAS A
LITTLE WIDE EYED IN A LITTLE
SCARED AND I TOLD HIM YES
WE WERE HOLDING UP A PROJECT
OR TRYING HER BEST TO DO SO
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO AGREEMENT
FOR THE LOWEST WAGE WORKERS AT
THAT HOTEL THE HOTEL WORKERS
AND I TOLD THEM I'M SORRY
REALIZING THAT HE HAD SOMEHOW
GOTTEN INCLUDED INTO THIS FIGHT
AND HE TOLD ME SOMETHING THAT
STAYED WITH ME IT WAS SO MUCH
OF AN EMBODIMENT OF WHO HE
WAS HE SAID NEVER APOLOGIZE
FOR HOLDING OUT FIGHTING FOR
THE WORKERS WHO HAVE THE LEAST
FOR THE WORKERS WHO NEED THE
MOST HE SAID IF THERE'S JUST
ONE THING I'D ASK NEVER AGAIN
APOLOGIZE FOR WHAT YOU'RE
DOING TODAY THAT HOTEL IS BEING
BUILT WITH -- THE PROMISE OF
A UNIONIZED WORKFORCE EVEN FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE IN ORDER TO
LIVE IS TO BAYFRONT MY DISTRICT
WILL BE BETTER BECAUSE OF IT SO
TODAY IT IS -- NOT QUITE WITH A
HEAVY HEART BUT A JOYFUL HEART
AND WHAT HE BUILT IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT THAT I WAS SO LUCKY
TO BE PROUD OF AT IN PART OF
-- THAT I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME
IN IN A JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY
OF PRESIDENT JOHN SWEENEY
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES MISTER
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF FRANK G.
HOLDEN THE THIRD FRANK WAS BORN
IN VICE CELLULAR CALIFORNIA
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR AS
THE FIRST OF THREE CHILDREN
IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE FRANK'S
FAMILY MOVED TO SAN DIEGO WHEN
HIS FATHER WAS ASSIGNED BY
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
THEY LATER RETURNED TO VICE
CELAYA IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX AFTER TRANSFERRING TO THE
VICE ELIA CHP OFFICE FRANK
GRADUATED REDWOOD HIGH SCHOOL
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AFTER
WHICH HE WORKED A VARIETY OF
JOBS UNTIL HE FOUND HIS CALLING
AT THE TULARE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE IN TWO THOUSAND
HE ALSO NOTABLY SERVED HIS
COUNTRY IN THE NATIONAL
GUARD FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
BEING DEPLOYED DURING THE LA
RIOTS THE Y. TWO K.
THREAT INTO THE UKRAINE
FOR JOINT NATO EXERCISES
DURING HIS DISTINGUISHED
SERVICE HERE IN THE NATIONAL
DEFENSE SERVICE MEDAL ARMY
SERVICE RIBBON SHARPSHOOTER
BADGE IN THE FITNESS INSTRUCTOR
BADGE FRANK MARRIED HIS WIFE
BARBARA IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT INSULAR THEY WENT ON
TO HAVE TWO CHILDREN SERENA
AND FRANK FRANKIE THE FOURTH
SERENA BLESSED HIM WITH HIS
ONLY GRANDCHILD AVERY WHO
IS WAS THE APPLE OF HIS EYE
FRANK LOVE SPENDING
TIME WITH HIS FAMILY
TAKING THEM ON TRIPS HAVING
BACKYARD BARBECUES GET
TOGETHERS GOING FOR DRIVES
WITH BARBARA BUILDING WOODEN
FURNITURE WITH HIS SON
FRANKIE AND SPENDING TIME
WITH HIS GRANDDAUGHTER AVERY
PUT SIMPLY HE WAS A MAN
WHO CARED ABOUT HIS FAMILY
AND ABOUT HIS COMMUNITY
HE WAS ALWAYS LENDING A
HELPING HAND TO ANYONE
IN NEED AND ALWAYS HAD A
FUNNY JOKE OR STORY TO TELL
SADDLING FRANK PASSED AWAY
ON JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH
DUE TO COVERT NINETEEN
FRANK IS REMEMBERED
BY HIS FAMILY AND THE
COUNTLESS FRIENDS AND
COWORKERS WHO ALL OF HIM
HE WILL TRULY BE MISSED AND
I REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED
IN HIS MEMORY TODAY THANK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
CASEY SCOTT MCKEEVER A MAN WHO
SPENT HIS LIFE IN THE SERVICE
OF OTHERS CASEY A RESIDENT OF
WOODLAND DIED FEBRUARY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF LUNG
CANCER SURROUNDED BY HIS LOVED
ONES HE WAS BORN JUNE TWENTY
EIGHTH NINETEEN FIFTY ONE IN
LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA TO ROBERT
IN ENVY EVE ROBINSON KEEVER
HE WAS MARRIED TO HIS WIFE
AND DRIED MCKEEVER OF WOODLAND
FOR FORTY FOUR YEARS CASEY WAS
A GRADUATE OF LAKEWOOD HIGH
SCHOOL LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE AND STANFORD SCHOOL OF
LAW IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
HE DEDICATED HIS ENTIRE FORTY
ONE YEAR LEGAL CAREER TO UP
LIFTING THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
IN NEED STARTING IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AS LAW CLERK
FOR THE WOUNDED KNEE LEGAL
DEFENSE COMMITTEE AND SOUTH
DAKOTA AND IOWA CASEY WENT ON
TO BECOME STAFF IN MANAGING
A TURNING OF LEGAL SERVICE
SERVICES OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN WOODLAND AND STAFFING
DIRECTING DIRECTING ATTORNEY
OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SACRAMENTO
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE CASEY
CONTINUED HIS PUBLIC SERVICE
SHE AS CHIEF CONSULTANT OF
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES WORKING ON THE
VITAL LEGISLATION AFFECTING
HUMAN SERVICES CAL WORKS FOOD
STAMPS CHILD CARE CHILD WELFARE
FOSTER CARE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SERVICES AND
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN CASEY BECAME
THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
FOCUSING ON THE ADMINISTRATIVE
APPEALS AFFECTING THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS AND PRESIDING OVER
APPEALS INVOLVING COMMUNITY
BASED ADULT SERVICES OVER
TWENTY YEARS CASEY WAS HONORED
BY THE WOMEN'S ECONOMIC
AGENDA PROJECT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
THE STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA HUNGER ACTION
COALITION BRILLIANT HUMBLE
GENEROUS AND COMPASSIONATE
CASEY WAS ADMIRED BY SOCIAL
JUSTICE ADVOCATES CAPITOL
STAFFERS AND LEGISLATORS
SERVING AS A MENTOR AND IS
SERVING AS A MENTOR TO MANY
CASE'S GREATEST LOVE WAS BY
FAR HIS FAMILY CHERISHING
THE ACADEMIC THE ATHLETIC
AND SOCIAL ACTIVITIES OF HIS
DAUGHTERS AND GRANDCHILDREN A
TALENTED MUSICIAN CASEY PLAYED
GUITAR AND PIANO COLLECTING A
VAST LIBRARY OF MUSIC HE WAS
PASSION ABOUT POLITICS READING
AND BASEBALL OUR HEARTS GO
OUT TO IN IN THIS FAMILY CASE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER EVE
HIS BROTHER KELLY HIS DAUGHTER
CATHERINE AND LOCKRIDGE AND
HER HUSBAND JOE HIS DAUGHTER
AMY MCKEEVER CHAU AND HER
HUSBAND OFTEN HIS GRANDCHILDREN
CASEY IN QUINN AND SULLIVAN
AND CORMAC AND NUMEROUS OTHER
MEMBERS OF HIS LOVING FAMILY
HE WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HIS
FATHER ROBERT MCKEEVER AND HIS
PARENTS IN LAW HERALD AND YOU
DRIVE IN HIS WIFE AND HIMSELF
THAT A MEMORIAL DONATIONS BE
MADE TO THE WESTERN CENTER OF
LONG POVERTY OR YOLO HOSPICE
THEY'RE CREATING A MEMORIAL
VIDEO IN CASES HONOR IN ANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES WHO WISH TO
CONTRIBUTE ATTRIBUTES MEMORIES
VIDEOS OR PHOTOGRAPHS ARE
WELCOME AND SHOULD BE SENT TO
AN WE KNOW SHE'D APPRECIATE
THE ANYTHING CAN BE SENT TO SEE
MCKEEVER MEMORIAL AT G.
MAIL DOT COM THESE MEMBERS
JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING CASE IN
REGARD FOR CAPER AND HIS LIFE
WELL LIVED THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY MR HOLDEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF THE
CRETA ISABEL SCOTT THE TREASURY
COMMUNITY MEMBER AND SPOUSE
OF FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND
SENATOR JACK SCOTT SHE WAS BORN
ON JULY EIGHTEENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR IN OKLAHOMA WHERE
SHE EXCELLED AS A STUDENT THIS
PROMISING START WAS A GLIMPSE
INTO HOW LARGE A ROLE EDUCATION
WOULD PLAY IN HER LIFE SHE MET
HER HUSBAND JACK IN COLLEGE AND
SOON AFTER THEY WERE MARRIED
SHE RAISED FIVE WONDERFUL
CHILDREN SEARING SHEILA AMY
GREG AND ADAM IT WAS A POWERFUL
PARTNER TO JACK AS HE SERVED
AS PRESIDENT OF PASADENA CITY
COLLEGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SENATOR
AND CHANCELLOR OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HOWEVER
EVEN AS SHE WAS ADVOCATING FOR
BETTER EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR
ALL SHE NEVER LOST SIGHT OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION
AND HER OWN LIFE AFTER CHILDREN
WERE GROWN SHE WENT BACK
TO SCHOOL AND RECEIVED HER
BACHELOR'S AND MASTER'S DEGREE
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO SHE
BECAME A PROFESSOR OF ENGLISH
AT SERENO'S COLLEGE AND WENT
ON TO TEACH FOR TWENTY YEARS
FOR HER CONTRIBUTION TO THE
COMMUNITY SHE AND HER HUSBAND
WERE HONORED AS CONTEMPORARY
HISTORY MAKERS IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BY THE PASADENA
MUSEUM MUSEUM OF HISTORY
THIS HONOR AND HER WORK WILL
ENSURE THE CREATORS MARK ON
THE COMMUNITY WILL NOT BE
FORGOTTEN SHE PASSED AWAY
AT EIGHTY SIX YEARS OLD AS A
RESULT OF COVERT NINETEEN SHE
IS SURVIVED BY JACK FOR HER
CHILDREN ELEVEN GRAND CHILDREN
AND MANY GRANDCHILDREN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN THANK YOU FOR
JOINING IN HER MEMORY THANK
YOU MR HOLDEN MR RODRIGUEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARRIVED TO DURING THE
MEMORY OF MY DEAR FRIEND AND
FORMER COWORKER OF MISTER DAVID
MIA SON OF THE MAS ME HERE AND
SEE A MODEL IS DAVID WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE AND
A SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER AND
SEVEN SISTERS A VETERAN DAVID
SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
ARMED FORCES ARE PURSUED A
POST MILITARY CAREER AS A FORCE
FIREFIGHTER IN THE BAY AREA FOR
THIRTY TWO YEARS HE DEDICATED
HIS LIFE TO SERVE OTHERS AS AN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TECHNICIAN
WITH AMERICAN MEDICAL RESPONSE
OR WINDOW DIVISION THIS IS
WELL AS FORTUNE OF TO KNOW AND
WORK WITH DAVID IN THE TIMES I
WORK WITH DAVID HE WAS ALWAYS
CARING AND COMPASSIONATE WITH
THE PATIENTS YOU TREATED ALWAYS
CRUCIBLE POLITICS DAVID ALWAYS
HAD SEVERAL GOOD QUESTIONS
READY FOR ME EVERY TIME YOU
SEE ME DAVID ALSO ENJOYED MANY
HOBBIES THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE HE
WAS A DEDICATED FAMILY MAN HIS
NIECES AND NEPHEWS WILL ALWAYS
REMEMBER HIM FOR UNCONDITIONAL
LOVE MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A JOURNEY AND THE MEMORY OF
DAVID MEJIA REST EASY BROTHER
WE HAVE IT FROM HERE THANK
YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO
THE DESK THREE PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST RETURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY SIX
NO FLOOR SESSION IN A CHECK
IN SESSION MONDAY MARCH FIRST
FLOOR SESSION ONE PM ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN MR BONTA MOVES AND
MISTER MCCARTY SECONDS THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY MARCH FIRST AT ONE PM